Hello, it's Crawley again. Today we're going to talk about the absolute financial ruin that follows a failing body.
Health insurance is actually a relatively new financial device in the United States.
The earliest contracts weren't issued until the second half of the 19th century, originally designed just to indemnify injuries suffered while traveling in railroad cars.
Later on, these plans expanded to provide 24-hour coverage, including losses arising from general illness.
Today, the basic purpose of health insurance is twofold: to reimburse the cost of medical treatment and to replace lost income in case of illness or injuries.
Imagine a family where the primary wage earner becomes totally disabled from an accident.
He can no longer go to work, the spouse has to stay home, or they must hire someone just to take care of him.
Savings are quickly wiped out, the mortgage is foreclosed, installment purchases are repossessed, and the entire family is reduced to bare subsistence.
To prevent this, policies offer disability income benefits to replace lost earnings. But how do we define disability?
Some policies use a "His Occupation" clause, which is the most liberal definition. Under this, a person is totally disabled if they cannot engage in their regular occupation.
For example, a surgeon who loses their hand in an accident can no longer operate, so they receive benefits even if they are perfectly capable of teaching at a medical college.
Other policies are much stricter, defining disability as the complete inability of the insured to engage in any gainful employment for which they are reasonably fitted.